what the heck is happening we're gonna
watch
brooklyn nine-nine an episode of
television
is one by fourteen hit like button
subscribe
follow us on patreon for full-length
watch-alongs where we got so many shows
over there
or the same tier you get the option for
highlights and
watch alongs included i need to build a
robot to say all this
and also thank you to pratham jindal for
editing these highlights for youtube
actually
jaden edited this one thanks buddy guys
i know you're dealing with the past hour
trying to just get to the site to load
this episode better funny appreciate the
funniest episode ever
[Music]
lauren scully how was your weekend it
was fun kelly and i hit the park
went for a long walk kelly is that
scully's wife or his dog
i think kelly's his dog went for a long
walk that's what you do with a dog
my wife takes the babies to the park all
the time let's play wife or dog what do
you do at the park with kelly
oh we just walk around she gets antsy if
she doesn't get outside enough
and then it's just yep yep yeah hey
what's kelly's favorite food peanut
butter
she'll eat it right out of the jar oh
golly she's pretty spry for her age
especially considering she got hit by
that car a year ago
was she chasing something into the
street or just getting me in the
newspaper
all right this is useless scully is
kelly your wife or your dog
i still don't know which it is poor
scully
i think it's his dog all right
i'm going wife one of us is bound
the description sounds more dog-like
yeah that's why i think it's the wife
the focus of our investigation is a guy
named brandon jacoby
he did seven years at rikers for assault
i spent two weeks undercover
infiltrating the gym jim fultrading it i
coined that
i think it'll really catch on if more
people infiltrated james
so we want to bring in the sarge his
name will be trent carter a personal
trainer bouncer and
assistant manager at petsmart it's the
economy what can you do
sergeant jeffords is just getting back
in the field what if he panics again the
sergeant will be fine
if you want to worry about anyone
panicking in the field it should be
boyle
damn straight captain
i need a favor my apartment got broken
into last night gina that's terrible
are you okay i'm fine but i suffered the
loss of many treasured items cash
and this very fancy gown with like a
magic eye print
do you have any connections in the fbi
or cia there's no one else i can turn to
to solve this crime
jenny you're working the police precinct
you can turn to anyone here you think
these buffoons can help
they're buffoons they are not buffoons
try the heel
i wish i had nerve damage some of them
are before no you don't
i was born ready and then i was not
going ready for a while but now i'm back
to being born ready
yes ebony falcon
his feathers are muscles
but you're ready for this right
absolutely i just need to put my
precious babies to bed with a story the
ebony falcon needs to read go dog go
yeah he does chest bump me
you don't have locks on your windows way
to blame the victim sorry i'm not rich
like you miss one percent
they cost eight dollars you have a fur
bedspread
and why do you need eight full drawers
of underwear because i'm civilized
one large painting of a naked lady on a
lion one set of joseph gordon-levitt
nesting doll
one music box that plays she works hard
for the money when opened
one knockoff designer can you just buy
another knock off
no i can't silly sue because the label
no longer makes the original
so the sweatshop no longer makes the
knockoff can you estimate the value of
everything that was taken
emotionally 700 million dollars
[Laughter]
hey sarge sorry about the mess hi cagney
hi lacey
the police precinct castle hey
yeah he is so strong but so gentle
he's like an enormous muscular ellen
degeneres
you know what i just want to let you
guys know that i love you girls so
so much
you know daddy will never leave you
right girls it really makes you
understand what he went through
i'm worried about terry
we have to get terry off this case what
why look i thought he was a weirdo for
having his year-long freak out but i get
it now
he has children what happens to them if
he gets hurt i'll have to take care of
them
if you have concerns maybe you should
talk to terry about it if he finds out
we're worried about him it'll get in his
head and freak him out
he'll lose his edge in panic yeah that's
why i've never tried to develop an edge
you can't lose what you don't have
no surprises what are you guys talking
about no taxes and tariffs
well frankly i'm not so sure that
everyone at the gym is gonna buy you as
a trainer you've been sitting behind
that desk for so long you've gotten a
little tubby
[Music]
right
[Laughter]
nobody in your building saw anything
we've hit a wall so what do we do next
do i just look for another apartment
should i buy a handgun should i buy an
uzi look
gina we've done all we can this is how
it goes with most b
e's let me grab your badge numbers
because i will be filing an official
civilian complaint with the captain
why did i just receive a civilian
because your assistant is a goblin
captain we swept the scene followed
procedure procedure is just
a fancy word for proper order to do
things yeah
[Laughter]
i gave this regular trainer the day off
i told him trent would be filling in
it was an interesting interaction well
according to my new cloud-based
scheduling system
trent will be filling in
i spent 40 minutes making that water
bottle pyramid display
this guy is a psycho
silent treatment we should draw him out
by not engaging no
the longer we wait the more likely our
cover gets blown i'll make contact okay
but just
remember you're not terry you're a trent
trainer and known hemophiliac so be
careful
you trip yup
black trent one of many
excuse me sir can i borrow this machine
i need to be here to keep an eye on a
friend
hold on i'm on my last set okay
can you go any faster i mean what do you
need leg muscles for anyway you're like
100 years old
socially acceptable for you to roll
around on a scooter lost the count
yeah one one come on you're not even
moving let's go
get your hands off me you're safer
bullying me
have you seen terry i lost him his
children could be orphans already
i'm sure he's fine i think the bigger
issue is the complaint i received from
us
in open defiance of gym protocol don't
do this i know we're friends
but if you do that again i'm gonna have
to suspend your membership what if you
become
me become me what
where were you what happened jacoby
wanted to do wind sprints outside
you know he's a mean dude but i think
i'm making progress he has to buy my
squat belt
i told him no he respected
that would you say your regular gym was
brooklyn bulk fitness
i work out there too never heard of any
trend i work out there all the time
really
starting when nypd hands on your head my
god you're gigantic what are you doing
peralta you just blew my cup
oh no oh no gina came by my house last
night to go over the case
between us doing that and her using my
bread maker all night i didn't get much
sleep
since you have allowed crime to win
eddie pepitone say hello to leo's sporm
a p.i these guys are hacks how do you
know if your husband's a murderer you
don't call leo now leo
spore oh goodness you know this guy
everyone knows him the picasso of
hucksters
i like that look up who picasso is
you blew our cover man what's my name
terry jeffords what is my name the ebony
falcon and what does the ebony falcon do
takes every precaution to ensure his own
safety
bad guys to jail and bad girls to bed
hell yeah he does except now that ebony
falcon is monogamous and too tired for
sex so his only indulgence is fresh
fruit yogurt
well so far jacoby hasn't given anything
up but i think terry's starting to get
to him
i'm not talking you talking right now no
i'm already in your head
i put all the trainers schedules into a
shared online calendar
hang on a sec who's this guy says he's a
personal trainer at the gym but he has
no regular hours
he always makes last-minute appointments
always in the boxing area and always
late at night and
look who he trains brandon jacoby that's
probably your supplier
we should set up a tactical team and hit
the gym and sergeant jeffrey should stay
here and keep interrogating jacoby for
as many hours or
years as necessary headed out to close
the steroid case
isn't sergeant jefferson interrogating
the suspect now yep he's got that locked
up we're following up on this lead the
whole team is running smoothly and
perfectly like a well-lubed oiled
time clock bite
what do you think you're gonna hire that
bi to mock us she's
scared she's not scared gina has no
feelings
she once said the best comedy of all
time was the girl with the dragon tattoo
if someone broke into your apartment and
you weren't cops wouldn't you be scared
yes depends how many guns
do i stole my knife nunchucks axe
do i sell my throwing stars this is
taking a strange turn
fine i'd be scared sarge hey
i'm so psyched you made it here to the
sting that i definitely told charles to
tell you about
you lied to me i can see that you're
upset but let's just sit down and talk
about it
done talking time to dance
fine but i should warn you i took three
years of tap
[Laughter]
how did you find out about this i'm a
detective sergeant in the nypd
ho told me why are you cutting me out of
the operation what that's crazy
boyle come in here and stand in front of
my body and tell him that's crazy
oh no wait wait wait i was worried
worried about what about you getting
hurt
i don't want your daughters growing up
without a dad i know what that's like
and it sucks
and i don't want it to happen to them
why didn't you say something to me
because i didn't want to get in your
head and have you freak out again
i can imagine how frightening this must
be i'm sorry we didn't catch the guy
yeah it's weird it's like one of the
worst things always happen to the best
people
come on we're taking you home really we
installed a second lock on your front
door
the locks on the windows by the fire
escape and set all your lights on timers
that makes me feel so much better thank
you guys
i would like to give you
these great the cool thing is
you can eat whatever you want these are
right there with you
you best friend of afin yeah that's me
i'll be right there you'll let me do
this man
what choice do i have you hit me in the
arm so hard they no longer work
all right have a fun steroid deal
sergeant
you're a weird guy jake yeah
you have any falcon no the ebony falcon
had no fear he's the ebony antelope now
hey my arms don't work can you scratch
my nose
yeah thank you how did sergeant jeffers
do why is everyone so worried about
sarge
he was amazing he made the buy took out
the suppliers but wisely didn't take on
more than he could handle
i left one point
that he punched me in the face several
times that does make me happy
guess we're being candid today
hey sarge just for the record i hope
you're on every case with me for the
rest of my career
i'm not scared for you at all of you a
lot
oh peralta my girls made your card to
thank you for keeping me safe
oh they're so full of potential
why would you show me this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right that was good
it's worth the hassle to get it to play
it's worth an hour of work do i have a
booger
i have concluded i do not have a booger
i am ready to talk about this now
wonderful take it away
john say all the points you want to say
everything
lay the law down say it all
go ahead please be my guest
after you ladies first yes that's what i
was waiting for
this entire time this was i you know
take a drink
is another fun episode maybe not like
the most uproariously like
laugh-inducing but i appreciate it this
one felt like it almost focused
a bit more on just these two plot lines
um you know not that you don't get a
little bit of everybody but you know you
spend the majority of it you know on
the whole liberty falcon adventure and
then you know kind of dealing with
gina's situation
and uh yeah i mean it's always really
funny to watch as
terry crews gets to kind of ride the
tension of like oh is he gonna freak out
or is he just gonna be in the zone
and you know like the the character
comedy they're able to get out of terry
crews in the way that they're able to
use his obvious
you know imposing presence as a fuel
for various subversions and little jokes
and stuff like that is fun i also just
it's
on the heels of the previous or you know
in the last two episodes we met his wife
uh and so now to go to his home and see
the kids like it's cool like slowly
they're like expanding out the character
side and then
you know on the gina half of the episode
it almost reminded me like that the
point of that
story almost reminded me of when they're
trying to coach rosa
into uh how to you know testify on the
stand
and you know they reach that revelation
of like oh damn
rosa's just nervous you know and it kind
of reminded me of that
with maybe a little less of a of a
visceral punch just because gina's
jean is gina but uh but yeah what did
you think sir
you're not done reviewing you know i
wanted to leave some things for
for for you so that you know i don't
just swoop in here with my
incredible intellect that is not
necessary
everything you're the star joan that's
true please carry on
onward i loved uh
you know joe latruglio and his
ever-evolving cloud-based
scheduling system
scully and uh and hitchcock are always
you know i appreciate that they
represent the true absurd
end of the scale for as much as we've
given the show a lot of credit for you
know like lending credence to its
characters
i do also appreciate the contrast that
comes with like
the whole prologue of trying to guess if
it's scully's wife or scully's dog and
we never
find out and you know them going and
like shoving
thumbtacks into his feet as like they
are
like the two cartooniest characters out
of all the cartoon characters but even
that you know it's
it's fun because you see the different
approaches to comedy
that they're able to tap into across a
show
and also episodes such as this
and that one guy who played the main uh
supporting like
guest star the huge dude that that guy
i want to know how many times he's
played this role because
you know he always plays you know giant
imposing guy
so and then he did a fine job of it here
i think that's all i i got for now okay
i think i've wrung out that thought
towel there's nothing left for me to say
no i mean you go to the gym a lot why
don't you talk about that side of the
episode you know how's the wipe down
policy at your
weights don't look very manageable here
go to la fitness okay it's a lot
prettier than here this looks like where
fighters work out
obviously they got a boxing ring here so
it threw me off there was an old guy
there
so i was like i don't imagine an old guy
who doesn't really seem like a
physically fit old guy
would be working out at this specific
fighting gym
so that really threw me for a loop i
don't know as a matter of fact
got a major problem with that
anything else that wrecked the whole
episode and now i'm
just focused on it and it's taking away
from all the charms and all the comedic
moments
and
[Laughter]
i thought it was really well handled
because you get this they set you up for
a terry another episode where terry
freaks out
and [ __ ] everything up but he didn't at
all
in fact he was a winner so i really
loved how
uh like the the reveal of when you the
way they capture that moment of like
focusing on boyle
expecting him to really be uh endeared
to
terry tucking his children into bed and
then the way they panned over to
peralta and you see the wide-eyed look
just knowing
like oh [ __ ] he's panicking
he's that one you don't see that flip
coming now like i didn't see a flip
coming
at all and it just made for a very
engaging
reversal on who's gonna panic about the
situation
and again like this this uh
the uh i'm fascinated with sitcoms
because i always like seeing how the b
stories uh thematically tie in
to the to the main plot um it's always
something i'm
weirdly like look for when i watch
sitcoms
and i think they really did that with
peralta
and gina two characters were underneath
whatever
facade they're putting on there's
something else much
much more vulnerable happening there
where like
uh peralta's very concerned because
he had an upbringing where he did not
have his father around
so he doesn't want that to happen to the
little girls
and then with gina yeah like the last
thing you expect is that she
in fact i was like is she scamming them
is she scheming them in some way did she
ransack her own place yeah you know and
then
to find out that oh she's actually was
scared the whole time
and then to find that the way they pay
it forward with showing oh she really is
just
scared like one thing that the character
hold seems to have such a great grasp on
is knowing what's really going on
underneath the presentation of these
characters
so i i thought that was a really
cool way to make her feel more human
because she rides this line of being
like a
a cartoon with a sarcastic delivery
so yeah that just made her a lot more
believable
and uh the first time i sympathized for
her
out of any of these episodes i felt
sorry for her
because of that fact of oh you're
actually scared you just can't come out
right and say that directly
so yeah i thought this was really cool
and then i do like episodes that take
place
like any time a sitcom goes to a gym i
like
gyms and basketball games and
like any time i play like a sport i'm
always
really into those sitcom like episodes
where or they're gonna do a boxing match
or something like that
uh i i really like those a lot and then
yeah i'm going to i could have watched
the whole episode
if it's just taking place at the gym i'm
for some reason i'm
really into i've always been into those
kinds of
episodes on cycoms and uh this did not
disappoint in the slightest not a bit
i could do a very boring realistic show
about the gym
yeah i think that would be good episode
one
waiting to do squats
they put two bells two olympic barbells
there
and then each person decides to do like
10 reps and then rest for three and a
half minutes
to 10 minutes
really just yeah be on their phone leave
them
free to rest as long as they like eight
sets
this sounds like a great quibby show
that you could watch at the gym but then
you know put down and have it be sort of
a bite-sized experience
you know three to ten minutes at least
from bite-sized experience
there are certain things that people at
the gym hog that are
very annoying olympic barbette leg
presses i sometimes set a stopwatch
to see how long i'm actually waiting
and it's gotten up to like 25 minutes
before
wow yeah standing waiting watching the
clock
my favorites are the bros the pack of
bros
the five guys who go to work out
together
and they all have a roll they're all
unique you got one guy who's a little
fat
you got the super super skinny guy
and you got the one buff guy who's
guiding all his friends
and then the other two who are just the
best students and who look
pretty muscular they're all doing
different plates
of weights on that one bar
as they rotate and then they do the last
one all together
my other favorites are the guys who are
like oh i'm gonna
work out do like my lats on the on the
on the bench here do some lap lap pulls
so i'm gonna grab ten different weights
here from the rack i'm gonna give two
five pounds two tens two twenties two
three
yep i'm using all of them i'm using all
these weights
just for me you could just use a few 45s
not gonna share at rush hour where
everyone's here to work out on their
lunch break want to see just how many
weights i'm using
and yes i'm going to take obnoxiously
long breaks
that's in consideration at the gym it's
my
favorite quality
but how's the wipe down game that's what
i want to know
terrible no
terrible no now more than ever there's
no excuse
one time i used um the most commonly
used leg machine
is the hip one where you push your legs
out
like they attach to the outside of your
thighs and you push out
the hip flexor or whatever that is yeah
yeah a woman love to use that one and so
to buff guys
and uh you know how [ __ ]
is this is that they only have one for
some reason
apparently they don't realize the value
in getting two of these
it's not space efficient so
they arranged this take
so long why was i talking about that
would you ask oh and then one time i
used it
and then the lady after me she took her
wipe down method
very serious to the point where i
thought she was very judgmental of me
oh no she like pulled out a whole bottle
she pulled out a bottle from her purse
and just wiped down everything you think
she works there
the surrounding area the floor nearest
water fountain
all the door handles even someone else
on a woman on a different machine
looked because i've worked i went to go
work out on the other machine
next to it and then i just looked over
and then the woman
on the other side of her her looked at
me
and just went
that's like why is she wiping down
everything
she's paranoid she knows something we
all don't just get vaccinated ladies
i don't believe in that but also i gotta
wipe down all the gym equipment
i gotta acknowledge the fate i'm
tempting here in this public pool
of bodily fluids i'm wearing a mask
there's stuff to wear masks and gyms
it sounds like a fun way to do that yeah
it's a great way to do cardio mm-hmm
sucking in all that fabric
it's a good episode all right guys we'll
catch you at the gym
we can wait 40 minutes together to do
squats
yeah or i'll be wiping down the floor
where you would stand to do squats
jt jt i'm
sorry that we have not talked
in a while i've
gone into denial that we no longer bring
you
a joyous smile however i'm assuming your
card is still on file
that you just get these automatic
renewals but then next thing you know
we're gonna encounter a lawsuit
duel because you're gonna ask for
a refund and i'm gonna be like
don't be a dum-dum this was your
responsibility
don't put this on greggy and johnny
so i'll just say this to you become a
jew
i don't mean that through the blood of
your dna
i mean it through the religion
per se because
they get you far in hollywood
[Laughter]
golly would you repeat that for me
i think i missed out on an opportunity
i wrote that whole thing just for you
that's a wrap
40 minutes ago i know it sounds rushed
but
i i prepared the whole thing and
committed it to memory
and then he rehearsed it several times
too many times
the point it just didn't feel natural
when i was saying yeah i wasn't
feeling the words to the degree i oughta
because i just said it too many times
david fincher's full of [ __ ]
that let that be listed to you as well
look somehow this turned into two
minutes and i'm i don't regret it
that's i don't i don't either i always
value our time together
done i think we're done it's really up
to us we can upload a video as long as
we want it to be
you see all like 10 hour super cuts of
stuff
we got time yeah no we're done